bonjour à vous deux ben je vous laisse
le soin de vous présenter je commence
par vous ou rade
ok y'a pas de problème mon nom c'est
malade de mably
je suis aujourd'hui ici à titre de
président du festival culturellement
l'african de montréal et vous hamida mon
nom est hamid abel mais m et je suis
peintre pluridisciplinaire mon nom
d'artiste mails alors vous l'avez bien
saisir on va parler à beaucoup à la
culture
aujourd'hui alors vous êtes là pour le
festival north d'africains qui a 10 ans
oui alors mourad vous êtes le président
de ce festival là ça fait dix ans quel
bilan
ben c'est un petit festival que y'a
comme ambition de faire un petit peu les
ponts entre les cultures d'origines de
cultures d'accueil on arrive d'afrique
du nord ça fait à peu près quelques
années ici et depuis que 2009 le
festival offre des activités des multi
d'ironie multidisciplinaire que ça veut
dire on touche un peu à tout que ce soit
la musique les arts visuels t'être le
livre la musique
alors après dix ans c'est sûr que on
essaie de faire ce diana et au cdh est
aussi de faire découvrir des artistes
dont soit qu'ils soient soient sont
originaires d'afrique du nord ou dont la
thématique hills et l'afrique du nord
alors on va parler des articulations de
cette 10e édition bruit alors quelles
sont les activités que vous avez
programmé pour cet et dispose pour cette
édition on est en partenariat avec la
maison de la culture de côte des neiges
on est dira au coeur de la ville de
montréal un emplacement idéal c'est sûr
que notre grand événement c'est une
exposition c'est une exposition bien sûr
elle c'est elle qui est chargée de cette
exposition est la commissaire dans le
titre est empreinte et mémoire
d'identités multiples
c'est sûr que mail vous parlez vous
parler davantage du côté artistique mais
côté organisationnel c'est sûr que c'est
à partir de ce jeudi de mai 17 elle va
voir le vernissage de cette exposition
mais la maison la culture aussi à un
excès un autre événement de deux
spectacles l'a1 dans le théâtre avec
demi moore had more summer harbi et
aussi à un spectacle de jazz de ce petit
de ces petits et puis avec samson band
prototype qui s'intitule comment
s'appelle le centre de les règles de
l'art les règles de l'art c'est
quelqu'un qui est monsieur c'était très
beau coup sûr le sur la musique me gaz
mais avec cette originalité et 7 ses
racines non africains qui réapparaissent
à l'intérieur alors hamida vous êtes né
dans l'art vous êtes né dans l'eau vous
avez fait le tour du monde de
pratiquement vous étiez en italie en
france
maintenant vous êtes en amérique du nord
au canada et l'art coule dans vos veines
oui vous avez raison de venir parce que
j'ai eu la chance ou l'opportunité je
suis né dans un milieu d'artistes
mon père était créateur modélistes et la
mer dentellière et je pense que le
premier enseignement que j'ai pu
recevoir c'était cette quête
d'esthétique et aussi quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile c'est la quête
aussi de perfectibilité que l'on peut
pas atteindre
alors vous êtes la commissaire de cette
exposition dans le cadre du festival
nord d'africains alors parlez moi de la
thématique vous allez chercher dans la
culture dans la tradition ancestrale
pour affirmer une certaine identité
en fait c'est mourad qui m'a proposé de
le chargé de cette exposition mais la
thématique majeure c'est avant tout
rendre hommage aux patricia rennes parce
que les dix années du festival coïncide
avec le 90e anniversaire de naissance du
peintre ici à rennes c'est un grand
peintre qui a été à l'origine de
l'avènement de la naissance de l'école
de la peinture algérienne post
indépendance et donc lorsque la
thématique c'était ici à rennes avant
tout le festival culturel nord africains
avaient rendu un hommage à issiakhem en
le titre était l'écorché vif
donc je voulais voir proposer ici à
raismes à travers un autre prisme et en
même temps nous sommes à l'ère de la
mondialisation
la thématique est le sujet de l'identité
revient fréquemment et j'ai ici rem
effectivement toute cette génération de
peintres
né en 1930 et qui sont font partie de
cette génération créatrice du mouvement
de peinture algérien j'ai trouvé que
l'identité aussi les a interpellés ils
ont travaillé la thématique de
l'identité issiakhem dans ses peintures
on retrouve beaucoup de symboles liés à
son héritage familial culturel berbère
et nous l'avons dans cette exposition la
conférence on a parlé aussi qu'il y
avait une conférence et l'envié où on va
aussi parler d'un autre peintre [ __ ]
dans les deux mondes génération même
génération ont fait l'école de paris la
même période sont revenus avec cette
expérience et cette
assimilation de l'abstraction lyrique
qui va être faire partie qui va être la
présente dans leur travail et ces deux
artistes parmi les autres n'est-ce pas
je pense que sont les majeures avec
leslie et puis martinez aussi mais
franchement fait d'haïti arrêt ici qui
ont créé ce courant de peinture
algérienne où on va retrouver beaucoup
de symbolique et celle de ligue parce
que le maghreb et l'algérie est un
creuset de cultures diverses
tout à fait et justement j'allais poser
la question par rapport à la
dénomination du festival vous parler du
festival nord africain et vous parle
essentiellement de l'algérie depuis le
départ tous les deux vous parler de
l'algérie dans quelle mesure les autres
pays d'afrique du nord sont concernés
par ce festival pour le festival si on
s'appelle festival culturel panafricain
en couvre on essaie de couvrir dans
cette édition
c'est sûr qu'ils ont et vous des arts
visuels on a focus et sur cette
thématique là qui est l'identité
l'empreinte particulièrement les
artistes visuels algérien d'origine
algérien et mais dans les années
précédentes on a toujours les
thématiques d'ailleurs le le théâtre
c'est un cetain c'est un tunisienne moi
c'est vivement les pas mal qu'ont eue
ici à aa morial c'est sûr il est
tunisienne
on n'a pas de comment dirais-je 2
deux thématiques particulières dans
cette édition par rapport au maroc je
sais pas ce qu'il ya des choses qui se
font en parallèle ici à la communauté
dans la communauté tout ça mais on
essaie chaque année dans chaque édition
d'aller chercher un thème on a déjà fait
un thème sur le livre du maroc on a déjà
fait du cinéma et des films les années
précédentes
alors cette année on a plus faux cul
c'est sur cet élément là parce que en
quelque sorte rayer le catalogue 10e
anniversaire du crm
il ya toutes ces interrogations parce
que ce qu'on a fait dans cette édition
c'est pas seulement se souvenir de ce
grand artiste là et que c'est que on a
des artistes ici comme elle
comme l'histoire la diète side c'est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment c'est une
gaspésienne et l'aîné ici c'est une
grande artiste qui est gay et il a
retrouvé ses racines bande son père est
d'origine algérienne et sa méhari
gaspésienne on peut dire ce problème
dans le fond c'est une dénomination qui
est très ouverte et très très inclusive
et une question à un éminent à présent
hamida on sait que généralement
l'artiste s'inspire du réel pour mieux
l'abolir et lui substituer une nouvelle
réalité
d'autres auteurs l'ont dit avant nous
alors dites moi dans quelle mesure les
artistes que vous allez présenter lors
de l'exposition répondent à cette
assertion
les artistes qui participent à cette
exposition
brad viens de parler de nadia aït saïd
il ya aussi ali qui joue il y a asier
marvel il ya le peintre et conférencier
miloud chennoufi hockey et moi même donc
nadia effectivement et de la gaspésie
nous nous sommes d'origine algérienne
mais chacun a son parcours de patikul
aussi dans d'autres pays pendant que
lundi qu'il joue a fait l'école de rom
et cd citoyens du monde dans le fond au
nom dont je pense que ce que l'on
propose c'est peut-être on travaille les
symboles mais chacun va aller visiter ou
les revisiter à sa nasse armagnacais et
va donner aussi l'interprétation qui
souhaite parce que cette exposition
aussi on a soumis un texte
l'artiste c'est un texte de marco aimé
un anthropologue italien où il parle
justement de l'excès de culture et la
quête l'excès de culture est décidé et
définir une identité pouvait amener à
une forme de fascisme tout à fait parce
que l'identité elle est évolutif comme
toi friture une culture évolutive elle
se rajoute elle s'alimente de tout ce
qui peut être à l'intérieur d'elle et à
l'intérieur elle est donc une belle
culture saine elle veut inclusive et
évolutif tout à fait
donc nous donnons se regardent plus tôt
et pour moi
l'artiste est sûr qu il il fait partie
d' il vit il fait partie de la vie
courante donc tout il a cette perception
il a dit j'ai joui la récurrence dans
son travail tout à fait tout et dont
vous parlez de l'identité qui est
plurielle et multiple a même parlé une
d'où le caractère universel ou
universaliste de l'ariège est ce que
c'est une dimension que vous mettez
également en valeur dans cette
exposition là je crois que bon je pense
que beaucoup de personnes ne partagerais
mon point de vue nous sommes fait de
strates nous simples comme la terre
l'estrade moi je considère les coutures
comme des strates lcf talent nous elles
deviennent elles deviennent mienne c'est
la culture que j'ai pu rencontrer
rencontrer le long de notre parcours
je vais citer à nouveau une phrase de
amin malouf lors de son dernier livre
naufrage des civilisations où il parle
que l'identité n'est pas défini
peut-être par un que par les racines
mais plutôt par les routes desmoudt
entreprises par chacun de nous donc on
n'est jamais comme à l'origine à notre
naissance on a vécu peut-être dans une
culture tout au long de notre vie on
fait rentrer dans elles deviennent bien
moi je sais que comme merci nous sommes
à l'ère de la mondialisation fait que je
sois par un déplacement physique ont
uniquement par les événements
internationaux et le web
on est ouvert à toutes les cultures
prédit si on les adopte elles deviennent
les notes d'un autre également et on
peut les interprètes dont d'alphonse et
nos racines en plus que nous avons
croisés comme vous l'avez dit on que
maintenant alors quels sont les
principaux messages
derrière cette dixième édition le
message
moi je dirais que l'universalisme très
souvent à une connotation
d'acculturation absolument pas je crois
que l'universalisme c'est véritablement
bénéficier de l'héritage de l'humanité
entière
tout à fait donc c'est ça c'est amp
parce que comprendre l'autre cette
altérité qu'on réclame pour moi l'autre
c'est moi tout à fait uniates a des
difficultés à faire comme comme l'avait
dit césar aussi ensemble quand je vous
parle de vous je vous parle de moi un
sens c'est celui qui pense que je ne
fais pas toi donc quelque part on se
sert de l'art pour faire tomber les
barrières pour faire tomber les
divisions et démontré en fin de compte
que d'humanité une seule exactement
parce qu'on va lire se rendre compte à
cette exposition elle est très
éclectique
ne serait ce par les travaux des
artistes différents et justement on se
partage le même
c'est très réussi à log s'est fait sans
les mots il y aussi à travers les signes
et les symboles alors burhan oui par
ailleurs vous êtes journaliste oui je
suis journaliste de formation je
pratique ce métier à disons pas à temps
plein mais à temps partiel sur six a
aussi bien la radio qu'un les clés oui
effectivement je suis journaliste et
critique dans je m'attendais plus au
cinéma les arts visuels ci venu un peu
plus tard et depuis c'est un petit peu
notre passion qui nous anime
moi j'ai toujours aimé tout ce qui est
artistique mais c'est sûr que en faut
que sens plus sur les images c'est ce
qu'est ce qui domine mais de fil en
aiguille tranquillement avec côté que
j'étais aussi libraires dans le temps un
c'est ma première expérience comme
professionnel ici au québec d'affairé je
suis aussi rang au tremplin
c'était une librairie et à la librairie
c'était il ya à peu près c'était en 2099
quelque chose comme ça sur la plaza
saint-hubert si tu te fais mon
expérience on a ouvert une librairie
mais je me posais la question
montréal c'est une ville cosmopolite de
fair use de tous mais ya toujours
quelque chose qui manque dans là l'idée
dont lé parce que c'est un peu
fourre-tout arriver avec un projet quand
même bien placé d'une entreprise il faut
plus faire quelque chose qui se fait pas
pour vraiment se distinguer fait on est
parti c'est une librairie qui se plaît à
mosaïc expression et une librairie
spécialisée dans tout ce qui est noir
africain en général tout à fait dans le
fond vous restez dans la et la culture
et puis vous tenez un festival qui tient
la route quand même pas mal depuis dix
ans félicitations bravo
bah c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup
d'ouvragés puis moi mon festival c'est
que chaque fois que je fais un événement
je vais aller chercher des partenaires
j'étais très très bon partenaire quand
mais l on a travaillé ensemble on a fait
déjà des expositions précédentes des
expositions individuelles et on a aussi
de très bons partenariats
moi je suis quelqu'un très ancré dans la
côte des neiges parce que je sais qu'à
côté des jaunes vraiment au coeur de
marianne et affaibli le tout à fait le
cette place là dans la maison la culture
qui nous appuie dans nos évènements mais
on fait d'autres événements dans
d'autres en place aussi dans la
communauté que ce soit de la musique on
organise des spectacles on a participé à
des spectacles de idir de du regretté de
rachid taha tout ce qui touche l'afrique
il affiche du nord on est tout le temps
par exemple dans cette optique là dans
tous les cas c'est très bien je vous
souhaite de connaître un plein succès
pour ce dixième anniversaire de votre
festival
mourad et hamida je vous remercie
infiniment d'avoir pris le temps de
venir nous voir
merci d'une tv russie merci de me
répondre et plaisir surtout ce qui
semble évident